[Music]
so what this matter who views allow us
to do is to bring together a large body
of knowledge into a fairly short
manageable piece of work that gives us
the best possible guidance on the
effects of healthcare intervention
research has been done that looked at
whether steroids were helpful in
improving the maturation of premature
babies lung
shortly after they're born the
systematic review showed conclusively
the steroids save lives in premature
babies just saved tens or hundreds of
thousands of babies lives and the moment
it can take to three years to complete
systematic review so it sounds quite
labor-intensive limited I was introduced
to text mining in about two thousand six
seven and promise of text mining was it
would solve a lot of these problems for
us and we're starting to see some of the
fruits of that labor now in using
machine learning to make this as much
review process more efficient project
transform is an artificial intelligence
project that brings together the
technology is able to manipulate and
analyze data very efficiently and
therefore allow the researchers do what
they do best which is to understand the
data and interpret the findings what I
love about all of this is that it's all
about that partnership between the human
and the machine so that we can then
better direct human effort where its
most needed so what we're doing now in
development with Cochran and the
national energy consulting for
excellence in building surveillance
systems which identify research up
screen and
we're using the Cortana intelligence
suite to enable us to develop and deploy
these machine learning applications in
the plant we've covered areas such as
pediatric medication error have tried to
see lots of work on healthy eating
obesity physical activity all of the hot
topics of the day so we get to work
if systematic reviews can be conducted
more quickly that means that
decision-makers can be informed in a
timely way improving guidelines
including decision making therefore
helping patients health
[Music]